[Music]
hi we're here at the 2019 Wolfram
technology conference I'm Silvia Haas
and I run social media for Wolfram
research and I'm here with my co-host
I'm Trudy Ponte and I was a student at
the wolfram high school summer camp this
year and we have with us John McLean who
is the director of technical and
communication strategy and he is going
to be giving us a talk on diagnosing
colon cancer with image processing so
what do you do at wolfram and what has
brought you to the talk well I have
quite a lot of variables that wolf might
be in here a long time and I've got
things in lots of pies but in the
context of this talk one of the things I
do is I leave the Technical Services
team in the European office so we we
take the Wolfman technology and then we
tailor it and build applications on top
of it that make it suited to the actual
tasks of the customer ones rather than
just giving them the building blocks to
do it themselves and so I'm talking
about one of the projects that that
we've done within that team okay awesome
so what is this talk about well we're in
a consortium with with the NHS the UK
National Health Service and some of its
funding bodies the University of
Barcelona and a couple of other partners
to try and improve the way that stomach
bowel cancer is detected at the moment
the ultimate way that is diagnosed is
with endoscopy which is basically
inserting a camera and fiddling around
and it's pretty unsatisfactory because
it takes a lot of skill you've got to be
able to pilot this thing it and diagnose
at the same time so that's a double
skillset it needs a hospital to do this
and actually carries risks there's the
risk of perforating the Bell because
you're clumsy with it so the the new
idea is to take these miniature cameras
that can be disposable II created into a
pill sized capsule you swallow it and
you get a video all the way through so
you don't have a risk of missing in a
bit because you get post off everything
and then reviewing that you don't need
any hospital you can take this thing at
home there's no risk and so there's a
lot of pluses to it
the downside though is that it generates
a lot of images so you've still got a
really big diagnostic problem that
you've got this thousands and thousands
of pictures and how do you review those
and that's where it's thought that some
image processing and automation could
make this not just feasible but actually
if it was simple and cheap enough one
could intervene early and be much more
ready to do this kind of diagnostics and
actually bowel cancer is very treatable
so there's a real potential upside to
this one that's awesome
do you have any examples yes so I've got
here some of my slides here setting up
the scene this is the kind of what we're
competing with but this is actually the
kind of thing that you end up with and
it's it's totally self-contained and
it's got enough battery to last the
journey and you just as I say we swallow
it but the challenge here then is how we
process all of this data so one of the
things that we're trying to do is to
ultimately do this by machine learning
and in theory with enough data you just
have to tell it these are cancer spots
than these not but the challenge to the
moment is we've got no real data so
there's there's a couple of steps that
first of all we have to build a tool
that allows you to collect the data and
then we want to be able to turn that
into something that that that will auto
die again so at least assist diagnosis
so this is here cycle it's all we were
putting together and the idea is you up
you select the video file that's been
uploaded from the camera and then we get
this validation interface here and this
is now going through that that video
frame by frame we can mouse over it we
can have a look at these close-up images
and someone who's got expertise can look
at that and say yeah that's clean you're
fine and there's an interface then for
marking all or some of those images
there's clean and unclean and this is
building that training set because
ultimately you want to go back in and
give the machine learning those tools
and have it learn what looks like cancer
or what doesn't but in the intermediate
step one of the things we want to do is
to mix human knowledge
and machine knowledge because with
millions of images the machine is gonna
do a better job in theory but we're not
gonna have those in the moment because
you know we're pilot phase so what we're
trying to do is to accelerate the
machine learning by also overloading
some information that we have that we
can choose from a human point of view
and so that's the classic image
processing we know things like there are
bubbles in the images so here's the kind
of one of the problem things that comes
up in images with an update we will
learn that above all and to ignore it
but because we as humans we know the
bubbles generally have these kind of
high entropy edges because they reflect
off the lights on the camera then we can
target those in a programmed way and we
have a some filters here to clinics
improve the images by removing
obstructions so here we've this D bubble
function that we've written can
automatically take out the area where
you can't see anything because it's
obscured by bubbles and now being
machine learning can only see the actual
bits of the year well and there's a
couple of other filters that we have
that are taking out things like
obstructions so this is some of the
inputs and the outputs where the white
area represents the mask of the bit that
we don't want the machine learning to
see and that way we can have it only
focus on the bits that matter so in
theory fewer images will still produce a
useful signal from so it's like the
target number of images for a training
set like that well some extent that's up
to the other partners to find generate
so you know we'd like it to be in the
thousands it'll be better if it was in
the tens of thousands but it's a bit
asymmetrical because even when you've
got somebody with summer cancer you've
got you know a thousand ten thousand
images of good intestines that you know
you know riddled with cancer less final
stages so you you're going to always
going to have a fairly small number of
actual examples of cancer so we need a
lot of those is the most important thing
that
from which unfortunately don't want to
see but in order to succeed we have to
see those things and attack them
interesting what inspired you to do this
project um well we've we've been working
on previous NHS projects and we've ended
up making some friends in the 80s we did
a project before taking some data from
it was operational data from NHS cut
ward and that was very open-ended
project where they just said we've been
collecting this for years for
operational reasons
there must be something useful in this
data tell us something useful you know
it's fun to do projects like that where
we just went through looking for
patterns and correlations and in that
project we found two really strong
signals that are kind of an amusing
example actually of exploratory data
because we found we're looking at slips
trips and falls and it turned out two
things that were the strong indicators
the ratio of trained nurses to unclaimed
nurses the junior nurses not the number
but the proportion if there's a lot of
Julian as his people fall over they're
not being synchronised properly and the
other one was that if people were sick
they don't fall over which is I know
when you think about is because they
stayed in bed yeah so they've a chance
to fall over and the logical thing is to
stop them falling over make them sick
which is not really once the Health
Service wants to hear but that first
finding made a bit of a name for us in
the NHS and so when projects like this
came along then people come to us
knowing that we can handle the data and
do the machine learning in image
processing and all of those kinds of
things so he came to us basically and
he's good to do something useful so how
long do you expect it to take for a
fully trained data set or a fully
trained machine yes so the project is is
intended to last between one and two
years we got off pretty fast by getting
Albert out in the first few weeks
because
well you know both language you meant we
can actually do a bit fly quickly we're
now kind of in the waiting phase where
the actual practicalities are getting it
deployed in front of people and and
scaling it up start generating the data
you have to wait some months for so as
soon as we actually start doing some
data really then we just are making the
steps towards a tool that will be the
next stage of this may be similar but
instead of just saying his image one his
image - the idea is it will start using
the early results from machine learning
to say here's the worst looking image
this is the image out of all 10,000 that
we think that's most cancerous and then
the doctor can review that first images
and say yes or no and then start
chopping forward saying when you get to
the super safe ones perhaps he stops so
it's all going to be an iteration and
the question is at what point does it
stop being a chore for the doctor and
start being you know useful once it's
once that is the worst image starts
actually hitting the right image then
it's doing something good it's the idea
was to make this virtuous loop that the
more you use it the better it gets after
this project is complete where will we
be able to get more information or find
it well though we it's publicly funded
so this will all be published at the end
so hopefully we have some good news when
we can make some headlines but it will
at least be somewhere in the journals
there is some a plan which hasn't been
funded yet but we're proposing which is
all about the rollout so we were
anticipating a success and and our plot
and that actually is still going to be
data science mostly we there'll be
maintenance on the tool that one of the
next steps is again practical which is
who's going to use this and who are and
it's it's there's some reason to believe
that there's enough data already to be
able to look at the patients and say
well for you this would be the right
thing but perhaps for you it isn't you
know maybe maybe for certain ages it's
it's
it's not telling that in a certain
hospital where they've got very
efficient and very cheap traditional
methods maybe it's not cost-effective
and we're gonna be doing some machine
learning and data science to try and a
convince the people who should be using
it for they should be using it and be to
allow them to use it most efficiently on
the right people to get the there
anything else you wanna tell us
um well you know my you know my hope is
that this is gonna be one of those
things that makes the world a better
place and I think you know the the
broader thing here is is that
particularly in health health is perhaps
one of the biggest areas where there's a
lot of unused data there's already a lot
of images out there that have been
captured but they're not labeled and in
other places there is data that's
perfectly labeled but isn't well
structured but biggest thing I see on
health data is access that concerns
about privacy override the utility
that's buried in this data and I had
this plan great feeling I'd tell us a
story sometimes of imagining my my
daughter when she's in her 60s or 70s
and by that point you know whatever's
wrong with her they'll be up say this
has been seen a thousand times before
ten thousand times before and out of
those we know people exactly like you
with exactly back in issue it and all of
the treatments have been applied and we
know which one is best but I can't tell
you because it's like a date oh yeah and
if we can overcome that barrier and make
it so that projects like this pin you
know access the anonymize didn't
suitably protective data there's just so
much that can be improved in health and
this is just one tiny tiny corner of it
you just multiply this over every
procedure that's out there there's
capturing data and you know a lot of
medicine is trial and error and we're
not learning the lessons at that
anything if you look at things like a
new drug a huge amount of money is spent
on a file for relatively small number of
people
you know clocks played on a thousand
people in very controlled situations and
they control away that variability you
know they pick people who only have that
one disease who are the white age group
because they want to get the most out of
that experiment the real experiments
when the clocks actually out there in
the market and it's being used on tens
of thousands of people with lots of
other problems and across a range of
ages and backgrounds and weights and all
of these variability and yet we're not
treating that like a valuable experiment
even though an opportunity yes
definitely well thank you so much for
coming in and talking with us when I
read colonoscopy talk it's definitely
nervous about it but this has been super
educational and and it's a simple idea
it seems obvious that we should be doing
this but but you know we need to make it
practical yeah well thanks for coming
[Music]